Gwen Stefani thank you I am so excited
and I I feel like whenever I've been
around you I've been like
I feel like I like that I mean it's so
weird because I feel like that's how I
feel about you and I like you were a
little girl star so I was a little girl
and I was like but she's so pretty I I
might actually I feel like I might have
copied you a few times actually the
daisies and I used to say drew here and
that's what I think I copied that I
think I started wearing Gwen shirts
after I saw you do that so
thank you
for sure
because here are we sitting
oh my God you're ridiculous hello great
if not toss it
um I
that's just so crazy to hear from the
woman that we all were so inspired by
and influenced by style wise and thank
you
as someone who got the honor gift and
pleasure of being around you here and
there seldomly but when I would and I'm
sure I feel like we know a lot of the
same humans but we do we had that one
night where we all went to dinner yes
that was the night I felt like I got to
talk to you the most yeah well it's
funny because a fun fact that I found
out about you is that when you were
younger you used to consider or think
about creating Jingles for KFC is this
true well I feel like I had very shallow
dreams like my dreams forever but this
is the stuff I'm dying to know about you
I'm like so Gwen Stefani once considered
writing a jingle for KFC I well this is
a thing I wasn't really that I had a
really hard time at school I was I was
dyslexic so I didn't really fit into the
whole school system I didn't know at
that time that I was I just knew that I
was sinking and just sort of like
sliding through and by the time I got
into no doubt I was 17 and and my
brother was the really gifted one he was
like the one that wrote all the songs
super super extremely talented and my
hero and I would basically I worshiped
him and he just was like you're gonna
sing and it and he wrote the songs in
the beginning but then once I like had
like my boyfriend break up with me and
then my brother left the band and my
life was falling apart all of a sudden
this song I just wrote a song like it
just literally came down and it was it
just wrote I think my first song was
called different people
um but I think that that actually ended
up on Obama's play playlist that actual
song which is just crazy to me because
I'm like that song is like kind of
embarrassing because it's like the first
song I ever wrote but he liked it so
there you go but and those are the
moments where you're like having a day
and you see something like that and
you're like
but I swear like I never would imagine
that I'd be here right now on your stage
I feel like I just didn't think I would
do anything but I knew that I could do
those Jingles if someone said there's a
Kentucky Fried Chicken commercial they
want you to sing this part I would be
like I could do it I swear I can do it
just let me try you know did you like
Kentucky Fried Chicken no I don't
actually think I ever
yeah
yeah my parents we we only um we never
got to eat out like we my parents never
took us out to dinner except for one
night a week we would go to this pizza
restaurant that is called Mama cosas and
if you ever are in Anaheim you should go
it's the greatest restaurant in the
world so and because you're in Anaheim I
heard like maybe there was a vision of
potential like Disney Lounge singer that
was the other dream that I had it was um
because we would never we'd go to
Disneyland a lot but we could walk to
the hotel which is just like really
clear closed captioning not available
Oh no you're like the Gerber baby and
Easter bunny had a baby
and I love this one I love this one so
much I remember those curlers so well
isn't it like when you see that you know
because we're kind of from the same time
grew up together oh and then wait this
moment I was so transported
look at your hair that is when I
worshiped you for sure at that age that
was ninth grade that was um I love it
like winter formal or one of those
things
and there's this cool moment that I
really love because I didn't know this
or realize it but then when I'm looking
at it I'm like well yeah we both were
inspired by Michelle Pfeiffer in
Scarface yes okay so this is Michelle
Pfeiffer and Scarface I'm so curious as
to what it is there's your album cover
sure so well yes and then here's me and
scream
um
what was it about Michelle Pfeiffer and
Scarface that inspired you I think it
was you know for me I'm always just
inspired by whatever's in front of me at
the moment I might have like just got I
was designing for lamb at the time it
was and I had a collection I just had
Kingston he was just born and I did this
collection that was all based on like
that that time period that kind of 70s
disco-e yeah and um and then I think I
feel like I put that record out and um
that's when I did the whole Michelle
Pfeiffer thing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]